so go talk about exposing the work
they've been doing exposing algorithms
No
okay so I'm a competition or journalist
I work at the University of Maryland in
the competition journalism map and
competition or journalism is really
about applying computer science to
journalism so either developing newsroom
tools for the purpose of gathering data
checking stories personalized news
comment moderation a bunch of other
things as well as using constitutional
methods to investigate our own stories
and in this case the stories that we are
investigating info of algorithmic
accountability and transparency so why
should we care about algorithms or
they're in charge of or have a big
influence on a lot of pieces of our
lives from using Google search to hiring
and firing automating through CVS and
resumes deciding like giving us
recommendations for things to use a lot
in the criminal justice system either
for predictive policing or deciding how
to sentence somebody or somebody gets
parole epping be it's everywhere so how
do they work and what what happens if we
think they're wrong a lot of the time if
someone if you say something's and it's
determined by an algorithm the response
is oh I don't I can't argue with that an
algorithm it's it's an objective
decision there's no way I can disagree
with that decision
as the computer is way smarter than I am
it must be right and a lot of time
companies will defend this position by
saying it wasn't us it was the algorithm
that made the decision it's we're
innocent but they're failing to
recognize that algorithms are written by
human beings and human beings write the
algorithm based on the earn by see
whether they're aware of the spices or
not and the agendas of the companies
that they're writing them for and a
number of other things so then what
happens this is an example of someone
playing with the Facebook algorithm so
he writes hey everyone big news
I've accepted a position trying to make
Facebook believe this is an important
post about my life I'm so excited to
begin this small experiment into how the
Facebook algorithms process language and
really appreciate all of your support so
he got 62 comments at this point and
they were all like number one or number
two in my feed so there's something that
the Facebook algorithm is doing the
detects enthusiasm and excitement and
turns it into an important metric and
then decides how your post gets ranked
on someone else's feed such a fun
experiment so I'm gonna talk about two
case studies I suppose one is a Google
search study that I was not part of so
this will be very brief and the next one
will be an uber study that I did do and
I'll go into more detail about how did
that so Google has an autocomplete
function as we all know and love and
then they're frequently asked questions
they have a section that says we exclude
a narrow class of search queries related
to pornography violence hate speech and
copyright infringement and that makes
sense you want to make a bit harder
people to find things on the internet or
to compete makes things easier for us to
find what we're looking for
but what our criteria for pornography
violence and hate speech copyright
infringement probably bit easier to
determine those boundaries but for the
others it might be pretty tricky and may
be very objective so what are the
differences between search engines as
well and are there any mistakes so how
would you look into this this is you
know so black box have written we can't
look at it directly but we can control
our inputs and from the outputs we can
determine how it might be working so
this is
a warning for for the YouTube editors
before this goes up
maybe so this is in the circles we have
in blue all the words blocked by Google
and in red all the words blocked by Bing
all one of them and two two words that
both of them block for whatever reason
and a bunch of words in black that
neither than block so they'll
autocomplete for those other words but
they weren't autocomplete for any words
inside the circles and it's a little
confusing because I I see some of your
faces and yours confused I am like what
is how is this decided there was some
offensive or unsavory words that are
completed and some other words that some
of us would think are completely fine
that I'm not going to compete you so how
is this decided I like that they do do
this you know it's how are they deciding
these things so this is the reason they
would prevent auto completion is also to
protect valuable people's and so one
group of vulnerable people is children
so how what happens then if you add
child's to the front of that
autocomplete does it make it more
stringent or lesser engine luckily it's
more stringent so fewer words get auto
competed if it's preceded with the word
child which is great
but there are some words again that we
would maybe think should be also added
to the exclusion list that should not be
gota completed so you know what is the
criteria for this how is it decided in
search engines are complicated to
research and they are you know how are
people using search terms in real life
in a we as experiment scientists can
only guess or we could perform surveys
to find out how people do searches in
real life but we're limited in some ways
- personalization to look out for we did
this was all done with incognito mode
and then there's randomization tests AP
tests search engines do and also Google
and Bing and other set
don't really want to be scraped so then
go into the uber case this is a little
different so this was a story that was
published earlier this year in the
Washington Post it was entitled uber
seems to offer better service to areas
with more white people and that raises
some tough questions which it doesn't
and this amongst all the possible kinds
of stories that you can look into with
algorithms this falls into the category
of looking at with this discrimination
or unfair treatment so the previous work
with the uber stuff so nikidik hablas is
my boss and he did some research on this
the previous year looking at search
prices so search prices are triggered by
cara quests outnumbering available cars
so demand is more than supply so they
trigger a search price which encourages
more drivers on the road and who
distributes current drivers to those
areas where there's a cert but he found
in a study last year that that's not
actually the case
really as tip while in DC anyway the
search price really only redistributes
current drivers surges can last for
maybe only three minutes at a time so
drivers learned that that's not worth
getting off the couch and getting into
the car because bad time to get there
the surge is gone so the current study
was well proposed that service quality
may not be the same across DC and we
measure service quality as expected wait
time which combines a car availability
with current and historical pricing and
other hidden factors so we decided to
call it service quality and if it's true
that it is different across DC it can
this be explained by a census data so
there's a bunch of tools and these
slides will be shed after so don't worry
about knowing getting all these down if
you're interested but the data sources
we use the uber API uber pie which was a
script that my boss wrote for the
project last year census curve which has
tons and tons and tons of free day
data then the sampling special sampling
across the district was done with
python-based GIS related tools geo pi
address and senpai senpai is for census
Python and it's the geographical data so
the shape files the boundaries rather
geographic rated information also used
FCC gov which returns which is a
government based API that returns an
address when you give it a long that
it's very very slow though and a bit
sometimes it would just like it go
offline and you're like oh I need to
collect more data and then we sampled
using a grid and averaged across census
tracts data wrangling was all done in
pandas numpy and stats models and then
there visualizers in carto formerly
known as cartodb and wisp is free for
three maps and then adjusted with some
Adobe Illustrator and there matplotlib
and Seabourn for the graphs and again a
little touch-up for prettiness for the
washington post publication so more
detail in the collection first we had to
determine how we're going to sample the
tracks across DC so there a couple of
ways we could do it two could be that we
just drop a pin one in every tract and
collect from there there doesn't really
account for the different track size
some of them much much bigger than
others some of them have a lot of
parkland so that's again difficult to
hide you work with with a majority of
attract being Park so how do we sample
that so we decided to do a dense grid
like sampling across all of DC and then
if if we have a larger track we'll just
average those points together and if you
have a smaller tract then hopefully the
grid is dense enough to catch those tiny
tracks and then that would be a 1-1 pin
would then represent that tract and then
we've got two temporal sampling with we
limited to three minutes because in the
previous study it was found that the
shortest
search time was three minutes so as long
as we got every three minutes then we
would make sure that we didn't miss any
surging and of course all of these as a
trade-off as a spatial
or trade off due to the fact that we
have API rate limits there's always
something to check if you're using API
is what is the rate limit I think for
uber it was a hunter thousand an hour so
if we've got almost 300 points we want
to do every three minutes it's like
maybe that's more than a thousand an
hour so then how many friends do you
have with uber accounts to get all their
access keys and then that's address
validation as well so we might have not
going to get all the prints that we want
but there's some of those what justice
might not be valid so I'm gonna hop over
to github real quick so everything's
open on github and we've made all our
code available so this is 2016 in March
the wopo uber paper and these are all
our files and this is no go up this is
the the the script that I used to gather
the locations from which we would get
the meet the wait times
uber so mapping points across DC very
descriptive so I measured the widest
points of DC longitude and latitude and
the broadest point to DC and chose a
beginning and an end and then create a
list by filling in in between with point
zero one increments so once I have my
long longitude latitude list are then
passed each long lap pair to this this
API that I mentioned earlier
this government API so if you give it
along that pair it will return to you a
full address so then we get the address
and I only collect if the Jason returned
has DC in it so my grid is gonna look
like a a square but DC is very helpfully
not a square so then I wanted to exclude
everything that was Virginia or Maryland
so then that's how that worked
and then put it one into a dictionary
and then make the dictionary into a data
frame and then look at the data frame
we've got our block State address and
longitude and latitude and that's great
but then you want to look at it and see
that it does actually fit inside a DC
and I've not done something weird like
flipped my long lats for example because
that would be a bad idea so it just
saved it as a CV opened it in Excel
highlighted the longitude latitude and
put it in this very cute little web tool
called a hamster map if you can just
paste paste along that's and it will
plot them that's nice we were a grid
that I expected but you can see that
there's like a ton of dots in the park
and lots of dots in the river and you'd
never ask when it and uber in the river
or in the middle of the park and I don't
know if you've found that if you're in
the wrong part of an airport you're
opening it up and it will say hmm you
can look for a car when you get to a
road and so you know it's important to
make sure that addresses were valid
otherwise the app the API wouldn't work
so we might get some weird results to do
validate the addresses I used a little
Python for tool called address which
passes the address the robot from yellow
API into pieces so like the number of
the street the name of the street that
it's a street or a road or an avenue etc
and I said as long as it's if if the
address has a house number and if it has
a street prefix make it a real valid
address and if it doesn't then it's not
about address so we ended up with
getting three hundred two hundred
thirty-four valid ones and 130 invalid
addresses so some of that was because
yet they fall in parks and rivers and or
on on our highways so again you not
probably ask for when you're on a
highway so they've got a list of all the
points that are outside they're all in
fired addresses and I can check this one
by one if I wanted or just go ahead and
get some new points so I added all those
addresses
then I had to count which tracts were
represented and which were no longer
resident so if the dress if the attract
had three points and none of them were
valid dresses now that tract is no
longer represented so using the the geo
data from the senpai api tool this is
all 179 tracts for DC I can count an add
a column to count how many of my data
points how many of my tracks are
represented and how many or not and if
they're not then I'll use the the senpai
derive data to obtain the center long in
the center lat for each of those missing
tracks so I've got Center lat sent along
took those together add them to my that
API they used before from the government
that will then if you give it any long
nap it will return an address get the
address and then go through the process
again a bar dating that address and then
iterate so by the end of that the the
bit that I could not I ended up with
five address five tracks that were not
represented so I had to get them by hand
in the end there's only so much you can
do pragmatically in the end the hydrogen
by hand which is not the best but I
can't think of any other way to do it
and we had a deadline as well so that
sometimes you just gotta do it by hand
so yeah then this is finally this is
what we get finally to see that we've
avoided the park we don't have anything
in the river we've got some nice a nice
distribution there all right
this is that a little bit bigger so it's
a bit clearer about where we were
sampling this is our sampling so we were
expected wait time from the uber API
Libre API returns expected wait time and
what the search price multiplier is so
we measured every three minutes for this
temporally the sampling was every few
minutes and we measured over the period
of four weeks this is back in February
there's no snow days so we made sure
there's no snow no interruptions in the
holidays this is like four weeks of what
we think is normal
uber function working and then if each
tracked we calculated the mean wait time
for that whole four weeks and we also
calculated the proportion of time each
track spent surging so a surge was
considered with the multiplier more than
one the census data we got from the
American Community Survey because the
census 2015 was not out yet even if this
is 2016 so we use the American Community
Survey from 2014 and calculated the
percentage of people of color so we had
two dichotomize race ethnicity into -
that's what I got amaze me and so that
was a tricky conversation to like decide
how to make that how did our customized
POC then we also used a percent poverty
as that often correlates with % POC
population density you know to culture
as a control dude you would assume that
wait time would be always be less where
there's high population density and also
medium income and then everything was a
z-score normalized so the processing
again just collapse across at four weeks
I richer than latest census tracts we
only used uber X because that's the most
commonly used car and then when so by
then don't we by the end of that we have
one value for ETA 1 ETA and one search
price multiplier per trapped under 180
tracts and then for the census data with
poverty income race masti population
density and and it's all normalized to Z
scores so this is an example of a map
this is not a statistical map this is
just the raw data this is the the mean
weight i'm perd
correct in seconds so as expected we'd
have my mass was working but now it's
not working
so in the center of the map where the
where the color is a light yellow that's
the shortest wait time we should expect
because downtown doing more people
driving around and longer wait times for
those in the outer areas and if you know
DC then you'll know that in the the
southeast the demographic is mostly
people of color and in North West it's
mostly white people but you might notice
in in Edgewood where that the Edgewood
labor wall goes to that's track number
92 point zero 3 which has a 75% POC and
they also have short wait times and the
reason for that might be because of the
universities and restaurants in the area
and as you expect Georgetown also lower
wait times and then you've got DuPont
and Logan just pointed out there for
reference so we applied a regression
analysis to this with the with the
dependent variable being mean wait time
and expansive area balls being people of
color percent publishing that's the
immediate income and poverty and we use
interaction terms for people of color
and poverty and people call it an income
and the stars represent what was
actually significant for that for that
GLM and then we have the graph which I
made in Seaborn I think that just
demonstrate that so on the Left in red
that's the normalized POC against wait
time and then in the blue so that so the
the high percentage of POC the longer
the wait time and the other graph in
with the blue line shows that with a
higher percentage of POC
you get a lower proportion of time that
that tract is spent in search so roses
mean ubers comment was obviously that
they're not erased this company and no
company is gonna gonna do anything like
this on purpose I mean a lot of it is
difficult to
create an algorithm that doesn't that
doesn't impact someone in an unfair way
it's a really really hard thing to do
also from our study we can't read être
Minh if the results reflect demand or
supply differences so you know maybe if
someone in an area maybe if there's no
one opening the app in certain areas
there's never gonna surge and so drivers
are never gonna go there which means the
wait times always long which means when
you do it from the app it's a long wait
time so you don't you don't use the app
and then it's a circle
maybe it's crime stats so maybe people
don't want to go to areas because of
perceived or real crime risk and is that
perceived or is that real the number of
banked or unbanked DC has a about
fourteen depending on where you read it
on what year you read is about fourteen
percent of unbanked or underbanked
people so that means they either don't
have a bank account they didn't have
credit cards it's difficult to use uber
if you don't have a credit card or like
a paypal account a smart phone ownership
might also be a barrier to using uber as
opposed to using taxis and with the
results differ if you were looking at a
different day or different month or a
different year so what would be next
maybe next is to look at taxi demand is
the taxi demand different is that
pattern different than Ebor as the
differences in prices accessibility is
at a marketing issue do unbanked people
likely to pay for taxis with cash could
they could they maybe develop a way to
pay to not be dependent on on credit
cards and thanks to pay for these
services it is crime perception in
different from real life would it be
possible to maybe include crime stats
inside the app or would that make things
worse like would that even be useful or
not and then transparency so we as
journalists also need to be transparent
so like how did how did I come to this
decision how did I get to this result in
my experiment so since we're advocating
for algorithmic transparency I should
also be transfer
so we have this work is on github in the
confessionalism yeah posit or e so it
provides an avenue for uber to make
response if they wanted or whoever it
was that we were writing about they can
look and see like did they do this right
have they forgotten something
that that's really important so get some
opportunity to check our work it goes
anyone else opportunity to check our
work as well so we can be accountable to
to others it also Spurs me anyway to
write better code so if I know that
other people might be looking at it or
might be using my code I'm gonna make
sure it's better and prettier more
elegant and it forces it Spurs you on as
well to make sure that the conclusions
and in the your thinking process is
right and that you end up with the same
story that you began trying to because
it's so easy to go off on a little like
a meander when you go through the data
analysis and you end up proving
something that you didn't originally ask
so this this helps to keep you all in
line and it provides opportunity for
other people to use your code or your
data so other people have used the code
and the data that we've shared which is
really great the code is one github like
I said everything's an iPad and notebook
with documentation and read Me's and in
commented code the data was too big
forget her get have a limit of 500 Meg's
so we put this in a zipped file in
Google Drive it's also helpful to save
wrangle data at various intervals so
that other people because I people might
not want to run your whole experiment
from the very beginning they might only
want to look at a set from a certain
point on I'm system the opportunity to
do that and if and when possible find
programmatic solutions that's not always
possible but it makes it easy to
document if you can have everything in
code and obviously everything is free
and open source so that was
half now we're always interested in
collaborations so if anyone's
interesting collaborating on anything
related to algorithms and accountability
then do get in touch these are my
details and does anyone have any
questions yes
service was
so the question was what was Eva's
response to the assertion that the
service was different across the city
and before we did the study I don't I
don't know what they would say before
the study I mean after the study they
just said that there is a generic
response that they they try and provide
the best service possible and that they
are always trying to improve and that
obviously they're not racist obviously
that goes without saying but I don't
recall anything about different no yes
yes may it's more you know how many go
where the demand is in there and you're
hoping to go on out sure if you don't
want to go like the downtown areas
business trips very short
I'm gonna go align the areas on the
outskirts because though trips going to
be longer so for me it's worth
beneficial so like that yeah your stats
are definitely interesting yeah but you
know as a driver I said I'm looking you
know I'm looking at the heat map I'm not
just gonna chase that heat map great
we're gonna try to to think about where
passengers might want to go and maybe I
get longer runs right yeah and there's
always this was a everyone's got
different agenda so uber has their
agenda the drivers have their genders
and the riders have their agendas so a
rider wants a cheap fast ride a driver
wants a expensive ride
so the surge surges
and uber just once happy well they're
just their business they want money so
so yeah it's like balancing all these
agendas together and they're not they're
not all monotonous ly converging on the
other agendas so it's tough to to
maximize and make everyone happy in that
situation but we've we've also looked at
uber driver forums and they're a
fascinating place to go if you ever find
yourself with some time to spare um so
yeah like people share tips and tricks
on how to maximize income and minimize
time and where they will drive where
they won't drive how can they avoid
picking out certain people are going to
certain places and and so yeah I've read
it at least one saying this is more this
is just a story it's not like a fact
that every driver does this but you know
at least one person said that they will
if they have to drop someone off in an
unsavory neighborhood they will then
turn the app off drive somewhere better
and then turn that out back on again so
they don't you know get get cooled get
requested during their time in that area
one of the comments to the article was
an angry person saying that of course
didn't go to those areas because they
don't want to insert crime I think this
I think the actual word was I don't want
to dying or something but I'm from the
stats I've done so far on the crime
statistics from 2013 to the present
there's no indication that crime is
actually a factor for wait times and
service so that could be an indication
that it's a perceived risk that's not
actually real
they'll cancel every request but even
though the drivers in process so it
looks like the drivers are not servicing
those areas the drivers are on route to
go pick them up then because it's vice
versa I can cancel on them make a guess
Long Beach yeah is that your own route
to go pick that person up that's more
than 10 minutes out yeah bet your bet
you're dumped on them I had pay to come
get you but that passenger is canceling
every request if it looks like they're
long yeah I mean that that kind of
really can't look at that from our
experiment because we don't get actual
rider driver data so this is just if you
open if we open the app using the API
what's the wait time for the cars around
at that time
any other questions yeah
that might be breaking Terms of Use
agreements
maybe I mean that's that's a little bit
beyond our journalism but you know
everything's available online so if
someone else wanted to pick that up then
that they're free to do so yes yes
oh yeah so the question was that we
considered controlling for population
density but did we control for
facilities amenities shops restaurants
yeah because I that huh tourist
locations we done some preliminary work
on that and there's nothing well that's
on my list of things to do
I've not found anything that I can talk
about right now but it'll be out it'll
be out soon yes little teaser any other
questions yes we got 32 comments and
some of them it was arranged it was the
range that you'd probably expect from a
wonk blog so some people saying that's
really interesting is people being angry
some people saying what did you think
about this and I did because it was in
the article so yeah I mean yeah you can
the link on like on the github page
there's that the title is a link to the
article so if you if you wanted to read
it but the comments are closed now so
they only have the comments open for a
certain time yes what would you like to
do would you like to do something yeah I
mean there's a reading scene question so
the question is do i what do I want uber
to do what I want them to do something
different and that's this is an ongoing
conversation so the the area of
algorithmic accountability is still
under a lot of exploration right now
people what is the responsibility of
uber is it boob is responsibility or is
it is it reflecting more city
infrastructure is it a government
problem so what what is this and we
still don't know I don't I don't have I
don't have a any ideas right now I mean
ultimately ubers going to go to a
driverless situation
so they've been turned to see what
happens then because they're taking out
a bias from the equation you know that
the human driver bias so that'll be
really interesting to see how that works
out but yeah I don't know
and the the research I'm doing right
there right right now with with the
extra data that I've collected to to try
and answer some of those questions that
I asked at the end I'll be better able
to answer that question after I've got
those results in so again tizi any other
questions all right cool thank you so
much